hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
Ryan Wright lumenok oh you said your
last name wrong anyway there's a new
Japanese TV spot out for a movie called
Godzilla and we're gonna watch it now
right now we're gonna watch it right now
what the [ __ ]
I just heard I'm sorry Seth I was gonna
kill B I've already [ __ ] her over like
twice today not only [ __ ] her once
[Applause]
Jesus Christ
[Applause]
that music man
right why are you doing run no no no
[Music]
whoa Oh scary
Thank You California yeah
what you know whoa no whoa that looks
like looks like a bridge no Godzilla
there yeah yeah point to your boozing
I'm like that so I just referenced your
boobs yeah that was a great trailer I
just love how they keep promoting two
characters more damn that [ __ ]
motorcycle outside I'm gonna murder that
son of a [ __ ] probably a moped prompts
a teenage girl as a chainsaw
[Music]
yeah a lot of people got murdered at
Halloween over nice
so like the idiot I am battery died once
again we have to do some shouting out to
some people who want to be shouted at
right now this is called Ryan and Sally
shout at you we can't really shows or
adults outside
oh man that other video had us talking
about diarrhea and it was a great
conversation you know [ __ ] I'm so stupid
GTA V Network he said I'm his Idol yeah
if I'm your idol you have very high
aspirations you know who should run it
you know you should produce it
GTA V Network you a guy or a girl you're
a girl would you talk if you're a guy
keep commenting girls can comment too
but I prefer to talk to them as for my
personal usage I don't really care to
put it in the video Zachery Thunderbolt
that's cool if that's her actual last
name good for you man you wanted us to
shout his name can't shout in here right
now so we're gonna do like whisper shout
the comic nerd 97 said if I don't give
him a shout-out I will somehow
miraculously turned in a Scarlett
Johansson which I thought I know your
Scarlett Johansson that's why I think
about you all the time primarily before
I go to bed sometimes you just got to do
something to relax before you finally go
to sleep right oh that's right you're
not really there